This is Philip. He gave up a high-paying
job in tech to start a garbage
collection business. Last year he lost
$150,000.
So Philip has a wife and a kid and
another baby on the way. And if he
doesn't fix the business model fast,
he'll put that growing family at risk.
>> Hi, my name is Philip. I'm the owner of
Garby Disposal Services. We do
residential trash, recycling, and yard
waste collection. Our revenue is
642,000. Our net profit is negative
151,000.
>> That's the wrong side.
>> It is on the wrong side.
>> All right.
>> Our net margins are negative 23%. We've
been in business for a little under 2
years and we currently serve 2,500
customers.
>> So what's the problem?
>> We need to become profitable.
We're not utilizing our assets enough.
Trash is a very capital intensive
business.
>> It will not.
>> One of our trucks is at half
utilization. Routes are not super
efficient.
We've had lots of unexpected repairs. We
need more leads. Scale up our
door-to-door efforts. We need to scale
up our meta ads efforts. Profitably
though.
>> Mhm.
>> And we need more conversions on the HOA
side and we need to increase our route
efficiency. So a lot of things we need
to do.
>> So many things. Why is solving this
important? What happens if you don't
solve this?
>> I'm definitely the thick of my Rocky
cutscene right now where um I left my
high-paying job at Amazon as a software
engineer to start this cuz I thought it
was a great opportunity.
>> Yeah.
>> And I I've been working 16 hours a day,
7 days a week for the past 2 years with
really little to nothing, actually
negative to show for it.
>> Yeah.
>> And I have a wife and a child at home
and my wife is actually due in the next
6 weeks, which props to me.
>> So.
>> I need to make sure that I'm able to
provide for her and my daughter and uh
the new baby, especially as you know, my
wife won't be able to work.
>> So.
>> It's really crucial that we figure this
thing out sooner rather than later.
I think we're really close because
>> Mhm.
>> by my estimations, we 3,000 customers is
going to be that critical mass point
where we're going to start making some
money.
>> Mhm. So, here's my promise to you, which
I don't normally do. By the time you
leave, you'll feel absolutely clear on
what you need to do in order to be
profitable.
All right, so I'll I'll stay as long as
it takes to make sure that you're good.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Okay. All right, so who do
you help?
>> Yeah, so we have two types of avatars.
50% are what we call scatter. The other
50% are HOAs, and there's two different
types of sales processes for these two
types of customers.
>> Yeah. What's the Is there a Is there a
difference in in in like home value or
income in the scatter versus HOAs? Are
HOAs tend Do they tend to be nicer
than the other ones or
>> We've had some HOAs that are lower
income, for sure.
>> Yeah. All right.
>> And then we have some scatter customers
that are much higher income. That
scatter group is staying out switching
to be an HOA.
>> Yeah.
>> Typically, it does correlate with
income. The HOAs are higher income.
>> In general, right. I think there's going
to be a big strategic decision that
we're going to have to make they're
probably not expecting. And it's around
it's around who the avatar is.
So, we'll talk more about that. The
second thing is going to be how you
acquire them. So, how do you help them?
>> Okay.
So, we have two different types of
services for two different customers.
So, our scatter customers have once
weekly trash, recycling, and yard waste
collection.
Most don't have an existing contract, so
we can just get them set up and start
service even next week, but typically
the beginning of the month is what we
do.
Then our HOAs have two service options
there. So, they can either have once or
twice weekly trash collection. Most of
them opt for the twice weekly trash
collection. Yeah, 80%.
So, they're on three or five-year
contracts usually, and so we wait for
the end of those contracts for us to be
able to bid.
>> reach out to find out when the end of
their contracts are, and then you just
have to put them in a calendar
basically? Yeah, Excel spreadsheet.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> Yep.
Yep, so once those are up for bid, then
we start to then we just calculate the
price and everything, and then we often
the low bid will win unfortunately.
That's just the way of the game.
>> That's what I want to talk to you about.
>> Yeah.
>> So we'll we'll get Okay, let me ask one
more question about the the slide before
which is
who do you help? So
of homes in your area
do you know what percentage of them are
scatter versus kind of like contained
within HOAs and like kind of off the
basically off the board until they come
up?
>> In my service area the there's a very
large majority that are HOAs.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> That
is interesting. Do you have any idea
what percentage?
>> I don't know but I can just see it on a
map and
>> Just if you guestimate it for me it's
fine.
>> Um
70%.
>> 70. Okay. Okay. Are there a lot of other
competing trash services on the scatter
side?
>> There's one big one that's really
causing us to reduce a lot of our prices
right now.
>> Yeah. We're going to We're going to
We'll We'll deal with that. Okay, got
it. Okay, let's keep going. So give me
the the money stuff. How do you make
money?
>> So for scatter customers we charge
$29.67 a month which is billed quarterly
at $89 and as an intro offer we offer 3
months free. That's not all in one go.
It's just on the third
uh excuse me, second, third, and fourth
invoice.
>> Yeah.
>> And for our HOA customers it varies
pretty widely. It really depends on you
know, the home type whether it's a town
home or a single family home. Single
family home with a big a lot of families
are going to produce a lot more trash
and then we have to pay that at the
landfill.
Um and so
it also varies depending on the number
of units
as well as the proximity to our current
route. Um and they're actually all on a
monthly billing schedule.
>> But But the scatter ones are on a
monthly billing schedule too, right?
>> No, they're billed quarterly.
>> Oh, quarterly. Excuse me. Got it. Got
it. Got it. Okay.
>> Yeah, I
>> You price it You price it monthly. I got
you.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Okay. Cool. Okay, so how do you get
customers?
>> We have four different channels through
which we get customers. So we have
door-to-door
and I currently go and do We're about
300 a week. I knock on 300 doors. And uh
my close rate is right around 26% and we
hired a
>> What's your door open rate?
>> Door open rate was I don't have that
ready.
>> Just rough.
>> I believe it was around
30%.
>> Is it really?
>> Yeah.
>> Dude, so you knock on 12 doors, you get
a sale.
>> Yeah.
>> You're so chill.
>> You can just like you're like, "Hey, I
got to get lunch." You're like, "Give me
2 seconds." You just like knock on 12
doors and you buy lunch.
>> I'm not the best sales guy, but yeah, I
mean I can even sell. So
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I There's There's some things that
we're going to do in the offer that I
think is going to help us out. But okay,
so door-to-door, $50 commission per
sale. That's what you're paying your
current sales guy?
>> Yes, exactly. And he recently started
with us 3 weeks ago.
>> Got it. And he's how many deals is he
doing a day?
>> So he's been getting better and better,
but right now he averages right around
five.
>> Five a day, I mean it's not a bad It's
not a bad gig. And he'll just keep
getting better, right?
>> Yes.
Like yesterday he got seven.
>> That's awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> That's good. That's really good. That's
very exciting. Okay. Now, you pay him 50
and he's collecting less than 50?
>> No, he'll He's a a contractor, so he
just gets all the 50.
>> No, no, as in for what he like He's
collecting less than 50, but you pay him
50 for getting the sale?
>> He collects the 89 for the first
invoice.
>> Okay.
For the first three quarter or for the
first three months?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. You said that it was You said it
was month two, three, four is where
they're getting
their free month.
>> The quarter two, three, four.
>> So they get one month on quarter two,
quarter three, and quarter four. Okay,
got it. Understood. Okay, that's fine.
Okay, so let's walk Let's walk through
the So I understand the D2D. Do you have
percentage breakdowns on these between
which ones what in terms of how many are
coming from door-to-door, how many
coming from paid ads, how many coming
from outreach, how many coming from
referrals?
>> No, I don't have those numbers.
>> Rough estimate.
>> Yeah, I mean recently I'd say 50% have
been coming from door-to-door cuz I've
really been
>> pounding the pavement, quite literally.
>> Yeah, yeah. And then we leave cards
there and stuff, and then people will
sign up after
>> Yeah, I did see your door hanger got
1.2%.
>> Yeah.
>> Super interesting.
>> Yeah. Okay. Let's Okay, we'll we'll
we'll keep going. Okay, so paid ads,
you're spending 600 a month.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, we have
>> Meta ads we run, 600 a month. That gets
us HOA and scatter customers. But
they're marketing we're we're targeting
scatter customers. And we also do cold
outreach, so cold email. I exhaust that
list pretty quickly. And then I I also
have started doing in the past 6 months
handwritten letters to members.
>> Yep.
>> 100%.
>> And then we also have referrals for our
scatter customers. And though for each
referral they get one free month of
service.
>> So, I'll just say this right now. If you
have, call it, 500 HOAs, which
represents 70% of the market, it's not a
cold email play.
So, that's where it's the
handwritten card, personal gift, drive
up. It's like you have 365 days, it's
like go to two a day.
You know what I mean? And obviously
you're going to have the ones that are
due, you know, with their own
whatever the renewal is. And so even if
they're on three year three year cycles,
500 divided by three, so it's 150. So
you go to one every other day, or you
decide to do one day a week where you
visit seven, and it's like you are 100%
up to date if you just did that.
Yeah, I think there's some there's
there's opportunity there. Okay, so and
then referrals.
>> Yeah, referrals for our scatter
customers, when they refer their
neighbor successfully, they get one free
month of service.
>> Okay.
>> We also fast track them after they get
10 referrals, and we just give them a
free year at that point.
>> Cool. Does that get a lot of people?
>> Not as many as I'd like. I I don't think
I've been good enough about nurturing
referrals, but
>> I have ideas. So, how many do you have
What's your sales velocity per month?
Okay.
>> Yeah, so we get total average leads is
217 per month. We close about 72 of
them.
>> It's good.
>> Which is a 33% close rate.
>> And is that when you see leads there, is
that from Meta primarily?
>> A lot of them are organic, so they'll
see our cans and then
>> How so?
>> Yeah.
>> And do you have like QR codes and things
on the cans?
>> No, we don't.
>> Interesting. That's interesting.
Well,
>> Yeah.
>> I'll write that down.
But yeah, they'll see our cans
throughout the neighborhood and be like,
"Everyone's switching to your service,
so
I might as well switch, too."
>> Yeah.
>> They Yeah, that's they just call in.
And so our average vote for HOAs is
usually two leads.
>> And you provide the bins?
>> We do, yeah.
>> Do you have a specific color, or do they
have to be a certain color?
>> Yeah, I think it helps with our
branding.
>> No, but so they do have to be a certain
color?
>> So they can provide their own if they
want.
>> Okay.
>> Most people just want our bins.
>> And so we provide we provide a trash and
recycling container.
>> All right. I have so many ideas. Average
per month you get two HOA leads, you
close half your HOA leads. That's great.
And those are somewhat inbound, or is
that from the outbound efforts you're
doing?
>> Yeah, those will we'll start with the
outbound and then we often times I'll
reach out a property manager.
>> Yeah.
>> Or community manager, rather. And then
they'll say, "Hey, not interested right
now." and then they'll reach out later.
>> Got it. Okay, heard. So you've got 1,000
scatter, 13 HOAs, 2,500 doors.
Okay. Let me Give me all the other
numbers, unless you think there's
anything that's important here. HOA
customers are more likely to convert in
spring and summer. Okay.
>> Just that our churn is super low.
But I think that that might change if we
increase prices cuz we haven't been as
aggressive for increasing rates.
>> Yeah, I got you.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, yeah, cuz I do have I have a bunch
of questions on gross margin, lifetime
gross profit, and churn.
>> Yep. Yeah, so our our revenue is 642,000
as mentioned earlier, negative 151,
gross margin 8%. Um net margin negative
23.
>> So how's your The gross margin seems
off.
>> Yeah.
>> So how is that How is it 8%? Cuz it
can't cost like if you're charging $29 a
month,
it's not costing you $26 per month
for each incremental
add.
>> So that was this past year, and this
past year was rough with repairs.
>> Yeah, the $100,000 in
>> Yeah, just for one truck. Like, that's
not even all the trucks. Like, it was
pretty excessive.
>> Brutal.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, so
blended CAC of $67 with a blended LTV of
$1,300.
>> And is LTV like like lifetime revenue or
gross margin?
>> Gross margin.
>> Okay. Okay, that feels better. What's
annual retention?
Or monthly churn, either way.
>> Uh it's at 0.4%.
>> Nice. Nice. Sick. That's really good.
Okay, so and then you've got marketing
at $1,000 a month. Is that it? You If
that includes door-to-door?
>> Yes, marketing with door-to-door. That's
actually we since we just started that
guy, that's going to be increasing
>> Yeah, way more, obviously. If he's
closing seven, that's three, you know,
that's 350 right there. Okay.
>> What else you got?
>> So, our numbers by customer type. So,
50/50
for our revenue. So, 300,000 for our
HOAs, and then um we have a CAC of
$1,200 with an LTV of 23,000. And an LTV
to CAC of 18:1.
And our gross margins on this are 23%.
And we have a total of 13 of these
customers. And the reason the gross
margins are off there compared to what
was last year is because I'm going based
on, you know, backing out some of those
costs
that are one-off. One-off costs. And
then for the scatter, we have 300,000 in
revenue and a CAC of $51 and LTV of
1,000. 21:1 uh LTV to CAC and gross
margin of 26 to 40%. The reason I did
that range there is because right now
it's at 26, but once we get efficiency,
it's we're very easily going to get to
40.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, you can also raise prices a couple
dollars and say, "Look, we go 10% we add
three bucks."
>> That's true.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Let me see the ads.
>> So, we have a total ad spend of 7,500
with a cost per click of $2.12
and total clicks of 3,500 with total
sales of 153 and a CAC of 51 63 with an
LTV of 1,000 just like the other ones
and then LTV to CAC of 20 to 1.
>> What stops you from just spending
70,000?
>> A lot of it is our our cost per lead
goes like crazy crazy high because it's
such a small area we're marketing
towards.
>> I'll tell you why. But, okay.
>> When I was doing it, I could be doing it
wrong. Um, but it was just it was doing
everything
>> stuff right.
>> You I feel like I'm doing everything
wrong.
>> No, you're good. You're good. We'll get
there. Okay. So, meds, I got this. These
numbers are good though. I get You're
saying that it skyrockets at after a
certain point. We'll deal with that. Do
you have any other
metrics or creative to show?
>> I have the cold outreach. It's kind of
skewed a little bit because it's so low
for our our cost per lead because it's
all all the data. Um, but this is for
email as well as the direct mail.
>> You're just not valuing your time
because you're the one doing it.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's right.
>> Yep. So, yeah. I mean, $12,000 to be a
700 to 1. Yeah, let's do more of that.
Yeah, it only cost you $174 to make, you
know, $12,000.
And you got nine more HOAs in the
pipeline.
>> We do. Yeah, I'm A lot of them seem very
interested.
>> close half, what happens to the
business?
>> The business grows substantially.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> This sounds chill.
>> It sounds pretty good.
>> Okay. You know, so what's really
interesting about your business is that
we have two key decisions that we have
to make. Decision number one is what
avatar we're going to focus on. Decision
two is what channel we're going to focus
on to get them. I think the direction we
go in will depend on you, but you might
be surprised by which way we go.
>> Okay.
>> If you had a wave a magic wand, what
things give you the most heartburn right
now?
>> Not being able to
>> Obviously, money. Yeah. But, what's the
what's the indicator prior to that?
Like, is it like if people paid you $200
up front, that would change the
economics of the business dramatically?
Like, is it simply not stop getting
leads? Like, I'm Like, that's I just
want to understand that part.
>> Yeah, it's more about offsetting some of
the upfront costs.
>> This is what I want to solve for.
Which is
I would like to have the most scalable
acquisition channel we can that can get
cuz also you said it you're like you
spend $7,000 even in a local area,
you're not even getting close to
tapping. How big's the the market
overall like on a you know, 10 20 mile
radius?
>> Yeah, it's pretty big. A few million
people.
>> Yeah, right. I mean like you're not even
close. So like I would love to see spend
at like 7 $10,000 a month on the
Facebook side. And then probably another
5 or 10,000 a month on PVC which will
have super high intent and have
different metrics around it, but we'll
get there for
us to solve the problem for good.
We just need cash in the first 30 days
to be greater than your cost of goods
sold and CAC
fully loaded.
>> Right.
>> So do you know what that number is? Like
what's
So let's ignore CAC for a second. I
guess we have 50. We can use that as a
placeholder or 67. We want to be bullish
or bearish. So $67 CAC and then what's
it cost to kind of like onboard someone
and kind of like get them going?
>> I do that all myself so I don't I mean
>> If you paid someone and you and the bin
was you had like fully fully bake it in
cuz we want to scale past you.
>> Right. Yeah, so to deliver
all the containers for you know, let's
say like 200 customers it'd be about
$500 to pay someone.
>> So that's two $2.50.
>> Yeah.
>> per customer.
>> So that's not big.
So when I say so you you know I'm going
to roll with this where it's like okay,
if it costs us $70
if we made more than 70 on the first
transaction which you do
what's what's something like what's
stopping? Is it just that like you can't
get more leads and then it just and then
it because you're at 20 to 1.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? And you're at least more than one
to one on the front end.
So like why like why not? Is it just you
just can't as soon as you spend more it
just to zero. Like
So, yeah, the issue is is that we have
fulfillment those months after that we
still have to cover. So, like they pay
for the quarter in the first month and
then we have to pay for fulfillment in
months two and three.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Which is completely it costs roughly
like if we get them all that number.
>> That would be for fulfillment for the
fully that's what I'm saying cost of
goods. So, give me the fully loaded
before you get the next payment.
>> Got it. Yeah, it's okay. So, um
for each customer on the Easter rods
$14.
>> Or per pick up per month, right? So,
it's $14 and you're going to pick it up
three times.
Right?
>> We have three pick ups per week. Yep.
>> Wait, hold on. It's 40 It's $14 per
month, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, $14 per month
and they're paying quarterly.
>> Yes.
>> So, it's times three, right? So, it's 42
bucks in costs for the first month of
delivery. When I say delivery I mean
like fulfillment, right?
And your CAC
is we'll call it $70.
>> Right.
>> So, if we get upfront cash over call it
120 bucks
you could be good to go.
>> Right.
>> Well, then let's solve for that.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Sorry I had to pull it out of me.
>> No, you're good. It's I mean it do
That's what we're here Okay, cool. Let's
come over. Let's Let's break it out.
Let's figure it out.
What order I want to do this in?
I think we need
So, I think what we're going to do is I
think we're going to go
avatar.
I want to get clear on this cuz I think
that's super important.
Two is I actually think we're going to
go offer next. We have to figure out
like how we're going to you know, do it.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh you know, facilitate transaction. And
then once we know that, then we can do
acquisition channel.
And then I think we're going to go a-
a- ads.
And then we're going to go sales
process.
We'll do some funnel funnelitics.
I think that's it. I think that's all we
need to do. Okay. You're at that in that
stage where like I like having one
avatar, one channel, one product up to a
million dollars or more, right? And
you're kind of you're right there,
right? And so you have two avatars and
like five channels.
>> Pretty much.
>> Right? Yeah. And so you feel spread
thin. This is me just hearing you out.
And so what I want to solve for is we
have to make this decision between HOA
and scatter.
So if you could just do one, which one
would you do?
>> I think HOA is a better opportunity.
>> Okay.
I'll tell you I'll tell you why I don't
like either of them.
>> Okay.
>> And then I'll tell you why I like both.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Yeah. So the reason that I don't like
HOAs I never want to have a commoditized
service where I get into an auction.
Because it's always just going to be
race to the bottom. Now,
the reality is that that's not going to
change.
And so it's like what business are you
really at? Right? And so the business
that I think you're really in is the
efficiency business.
So fundamentally like if you if if 70%
of the market is owned by HOAs and they
continue to glob more and more, you
know, more of these houses continue to
glob together then it's kind of an in
uh eventuality, right? That that
happens.
So
figuring out the HOA offer, I think,
makes sense from a future-proofing
perspective. But the strategy of the
business has to be geared towards
because it's the only way you're going
to beat the other players. Because I
agree, I think they're going to
commoditize you and I think they're
going to make it lowest lowest bid,
fundamentally. The reason that I like
scatter in the short term is that you
can price more aggressively, you can
have higher gross margins, you can
outmarket, you know, your competition.
There's still a decent amount of market
share that's there.
But and acquiring them is super easy. If
you just knock on 12 doors and get a
sales like, all right, well how many
doors do you need to knock on?
>> That's true. yeah.
>> very straightforward. Yeah. Because like
taking it to the hypothetical extreme,
it's like okay, what stops me from
running an ad, getting 10 guys, getting
them into a room, taking a day to have
that, you know, to train to train them,
and then all of a sudden I've got 10
guys doing five or five to seven sales a
day, all on contract with no risk. That
sounds relatively appealing. And the
nice thing with door-to-door is that
they already naturally have a route.
Right, which you already know. And so it
it makes it even more efficient for the
business, right, on the back end. So,
that's what I like about Scatter. But I
do think that there's
this, you know, long, long term, there's
there's probably some downside risk. Or
sorry, yeah, there's some risk. The HOA,
I just feel like you're going to
continue to get squeezed. Yeah, that's
the only So,
you're like, okay, well then which one
should I do?
>> You know, what if I add something?
>> Yeah, go for it.
>> I think that the thing with Scatter
that's even better, too, and the reason
I said HOA was not really because of
>> No, you're good.
>> Like the I like I like HOAs because I
think that the competitor that we have
right now that's really aggressive is
really going hard Scatter and no HOAs.
So like it'll And then a competitor that
only does HOAs was recently acquired, so
people are unhappy with them, so then it
kind of opens it up for me.
But the thing I love about Scatter is
what you said about pricing, and then
also the fact that it's only once weekly
collection, so we increase throughput
for each truck.
>> Mhm. So.
>> That's the thing I like about it, but in
terms of, you know, me being one guy I'm
I guess I'm just thinking about it in a
limited sense where I'm I'm like, I'm
only one guy. How many doors can I knock
on in a day, you know?
>> That's not going to be you, man.
>> Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
>> So we just I mean, let's think of it
this way. You said when you get to 3,000
doors is when you're like super
profitable, right? Or like it becomes
more profitable.
And if we get to 5,000 doors, then
you're like we're good. You're You're
yeah, you're good.
Well, I mean, in my mind I like to think
like if I had to take this to its
natural extreme and I only had have one
thing be true. Cuz I like I like to like
make a plan on like the fewest
need-to-believes as possible. Like every
single new assumption that we introduce
like dramatically decrease the
likelihood it occurs. If I said, "All
right,
do you think it's humanly possible to
get 10 people to work on commission to
knock these doors
and get to, let's say conservatively,
five a day? Right? Now, this guy's going
to keep getting better. He's 3 weeks in,
he's already doing seven. Fine. But like
let's just say they stick to five a day.
>> Yeah.
>> That's 50 sales a day. That's 1,500 a
month.
You're looking at $20,000 by the end of
the year.
>> That's
>> Right. And so to me it's like, "Okay,
well, that overshoots our goal by like,
you know, 8x."
>> Yeah.
>> So,
there's all these things that you're
doing, but if it was like if only that
one thing were true,
then what are the other need-to-believes
that are associated with that? Which is
that you can find the houses to do these
door knocking on. Do you have the
ability to do that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, so knowing where to go is not a
problem.
>> Yeah.
>> And so basically your ability to solve
two things. One is the cash to pay the
sales people, that they collect as much
as you owe them, and that you can cover
the cost of
the first, you know, the $42 that we
went over earlier.
And so like if the only thing you did
was like you went home
and you're like, "I'm going to go find
10 dudes, and they will be commission
only,
and I will just rejig the offer so that
I can get $42 plus what I have to pay
them up front,
we don't have to talk about anything
else.
>> Yeah.
Let's do it.
>> I mean like I can go through like I can
look at the ads and I can tell you what
I think like could be better. I can tell
you why the the which, you know, we can
go through some of those things.
But fundamentally like I just want to be
like, "Here's the ram rod. Like if only
this were true,
then what stops me from doing that?" Not
a ton, which is just the offer and
getting the sales guys on. Yeah.
And then after that's done, it's like
that's it.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we just And then we just jam
it. And then you just don't let yourself
get distracted.
>> Right.
>> I will give you my my blessing on if you
get an inbound HOA, you can close them.
But I still would be like, this is our
growth strategy. I mean like, yeah,
sure. Except for money provided it
doesn't There's it's super operationally
efficient. It does take some of your
time. Fine, you're the owner, you can
close big deals. But by and large, I
think that's the play.
>> Okay. All right, great. So, I think we
go scatter.
Great. That was decision number one.
>> Yep.
>> Now, acquisition channel,
you already have 50% coming from door to
door.
So, that gives us that one, right? So,
I'm going to hit the sales process in a
second, but I think we need to go on
offer because this is kind of the big
the big unlock of this business. All
right, so
we have to get You said you're going to
pay them 50, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, here's how I would restructure
this.
I would say
we have to get $42 no matter what.
Period, cuz that's what it costs. That's
hard costs, right? So, this is base.
Then, got to get the sales guy paid. So,
I'm just going to put commission here,
which we can fill in in a second. So, we
kind of backfill that. Okay, we have to
get a commission and we have to get the
contract, right? So, what I want to do
is find something So, do you give them
all a new bin or can they get like a Do
they get like somebody else's bin or
like how's that work?
>> We recycle the bins. So, if someone like
the three people who canceled, then
we'll
But for the most part, they're new bins.
>> They're new bins, yeah. Okay.
>> And we'll finance them over
3 years. We You Before I bought them
with cash, but then I'm like, okay,
maybe we should probably hold on to more
cash.
>> You Wait, you used to pay for them in
cash?
>> Yeah.
>> And you financed them?
>> Now I'm financing them, yeah.
>> And do the customer is that $14 per
month including included
>> Yes, yes.
>> How much does it cost for a bin?
>> For the set including freight, it's 116.
>> All right, so it's 116.
Okay. Now, so this is bin.
What else can you sell up front?
>> Bulk pick up maybe.
Um
>> But only how many what percentage
customers like opt for that?
>> That's also seasonal and that's So no,
that's not the case for
>> Yeah. Okay, what else? So I'll tell you
I I have this idea. So we're we talked
about the QR code earlier.
>> Mhm.
>> So what I was thinking about doing was
like
you put the just the ugliest massive QR
code on there and you just say, "Hey, if
you want to not have this big QR code on
there, it's it's an extra five bucks a
month."
>> Mhm.
>> Or if you're cool with it and you're
still like are cool with us advertising
the business, you allow us to leave it
on.
>> Okay.
>> And I think a lot of people don't give a
[__]
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And so all we're going to do
though is just tack that onto your
existing pricing. So you're So if they
say, "I don't want
the QR code." Then they're going to pay
$5 more than your existing price.
>> Mhm.
So there
>> We bake in a little price increase
there.
So we get $5 for the QR code.
So go buy stickers. They're like not
expensive.
>> Yep.
>> And just put this massive QR code and
put your phone number and put your Like
you've got this you've got this
billboard.
>> Right.
>> That's just sitting out there.
>> What color are the bins?
>> Gray.
>> Man. I totally want them to be neon
orange.
I'm dead serious. I would I would
Everyone would be like, "Jesus.
What is this company?" But they would
notice it, right? I mean that's what
you're trying to you're trying to stand
out.
>> Yeah.
>> You said Wait, didn't you say that you
wanted the branding? You wanted it to be
on brand with the gray?
>> Yeah, and people We're like clean and
stuff.
>> I didn't think gray's clean.
>> It looks You should look at them. They
look pretty clean.
>> We have people calling in saying like,
"I seen your nice clean bins."
>> so gray. It's like the perfect gray.
>> Well, they're like a light gray.
>> 50 shades. Anyways, um okay.
Okay, this is this is the this is how we
break This is how we solve the business.
>> Right.
>> So, like let's take the time on this.
The other stuff is really easy. I'll
show you some easy Like I don't even
Like I can't get into ads. I can't get
into the funnel.
Like if we just do this, we win.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you don't charge them anything
for the bin, right? That's far as
they're concerned.
>> We do have a separate process through
our website. So, we at the door we have
that offer that I mentioned, but then
when they go to our website, enter in
their address, and everything and they
qualify, they do get charged a $37
initiation fee, and then they get
charged 35 a month.
>> Mhm.
>> So, we have a little higher price point
if they don't take advantage of that.
But most people do the door-to-door.
>> And so, this 42 is labor, right?
>> Yes.
>> Labor plus trucks breaking.
>> Yeah, and dump fees.
>> Okay, yeah. Plus dump. Okay, got it. I
think our key is actually how we
structure this, the bin. So, it costs
you 116. Is there a way that we could be
like
Cuz what I want to do is You see where
I'm going with this, right?
>> Yep.
>> Cuz like if we can get the first
transaction to be like 199,
you're covered. Right? Cuz you've got
like So, if we add this together, we've
got 158. So, 158 is the true like cost
cost, right? Of of getting this person
set up.
Then you have the commission,
which is 50. So, 208 all in, if we got
that, you're like
>> Yeah, set.
>> Right.
>> Something I've been playing around with
is maybe doing
only doing the 3 months free if they pay
annually up front.
>> Yeah, totally.
>> And then like downsell to the 89 a
quarter with no months free.
>> Mhm.
I like that.
>> Yep.
>> I like that.
>> Cuz even the rate is really attractive,
but the I mean the only negative about
that is sometimes they're like, "Yeah,
sure, let's do it."
And then they opt out because their
current provider matched it. But then
the 3 months free usually is what puts
them over the edge cuz the current
provider will not offer the 3 months
free.
But out of those that do that, I would
say it's only maybe one in eight would
really
>> Would do the pre-pay?
>> Oh, would um would like after we like
okay, it's 89 a quarter and they're like
yeah, actually my current provider
matched it. So, it's like one in eight
people.
>> And most people are just like here, just
take the business.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Yeah, so if if we get if we get the the
deal on seven out of eight, who cares?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Right, good point, yeah. So, if we go
what I'm trying to play with is so we've
got the what what levers do we have,
right? So, levers that we have this
little QR code like we're going to make
your thing look ugly. That's thing one.
>> Okay.
>> Thing two is we have the bin. Thing two
we have Thing three is we have the
commitment, right?
>> Right.
>> These are
this is like what we're These are our
puzzle pieces.
Okay.
But I want to collect 200.
That's what I'm trying to do.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
So, a quarter is 89, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, any reason do you think anyone's
going to balk at 99?
89 to 99?
>> A lot of people are paying 105, so it
may not get them over the edge.
>> You mean it's not enough savings?
>> Yeah.
>> I hate being low low cost.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> But I think that there's still some
people who would definitely convert cuz
like there's some people I talked to who
are being charged like 180 a quarter.
>> Yeah.
>> It just all varies, you know, depending
on if you if you call them to say, "Hey,
lower my rate."
>> So, 80 So, okay, so we got 90 90 is 180,
right, in terms of cash,
>> Mhm.
>> right? There's going to be some setup
fee,
right, which we could say we have a 42
and we also have setup fee, right? So,
that's another little little thing.
>> Mhm.
>> We're just we're constructing an offer
right now. That's literally what we're
doing, okay?
Um cuz you could do 3 months free
and it's 33 per month, right?
>> Mhm.
>> You could still do 3 months free.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that works fine.
Oh, here we go.
So, we can basically have the QR code be
our $5 extra a month
and you're at 29, so that gets you to
35.
>> Okay.
>> Right? Or you can make it
Yeah.
That's fine.
So, that gets us to
$35
per month.
Right? And so, if we did times six,
then that's going to be two
What's that? That's 30 plus 180, so 210.
All right, so it's going to be 210 in
cash.
And if you commit to six,
and you normally just eat this, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, if you commit to six, we'll give you
our $116 bin
for free.
And we'll waive
our
$49 setup.
>> So, can you talk a little bit more about
these
these numbers right here?
>> Yeah, so this Yeah, so $35 a month is
the the price, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But, what we're trying to do is get them
to prepay for six months.
>> Okay.
>> So, that's the main offer. Is you prepay
for six, and then that gets you a free
bin, and we waive the setup fee.
>> Okay.
>> If you don't prepay for six, you can
prepay for three, and we'll give you
Actually, maybe we'll just do this.
We'll do this.
We'll do 12, and we'll step down to six,
and then we'll step down to three, which
is your current offer.
>> Okay.
>> So, 12 months gets you
cuz what we're looking for here is
blended average cash per door.
So, if you have some people who pay 420,
and even if it's like one out of
whatever, one out of five pays 420,
we're still effectively adding 80 bucks
per door in cash collected.
>> Okay.
>> So, even if the vast majority of people
If everybody took If four out of five
took the your current offer, and then
one out of five takes the 400, it's like
we're still adding 80 with the existing
whatever 89ers that that you're getting
right now. So now our actual blended
average goes to like 170 a door.
>> Okay.
>> So it makes sense?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Okay. So
I think we go
times this. Now if they're like, "I
don't want the QR code." Then we're
like, "Fine, we'll drop it to 30."
Right? If they don't want this.
And times 12, so that's 360.
We get that up front, which is going to
lower turn anyways. If they say no, I
don't want to do that.
Then we say cuz with that you get free
bin and free wave. Or like free free
setup, right?
If they say no, I'll just do six, which
would then get us the two
whatever the $200-ish price point. We
can get to We can finalize the prices in
a second, but you get your $200-ish
price.
Um and when you do that, we can't wave
the bin. Oh, we can wave the setup fee.
But we're going to add We're just we'll
finance this over the duration. So
that's where you can get the difference
in terms of the Like it's $35 a month if
you do 6 months. It's $30 a month if you
do 12 months. Um and if you're doing
just month to month, if you sign up
today, I'll let you wave this fee, but
you still got to pay three.
>> Okay.
>> How's that feel?
>> Complicated.
>> Yeah. Well, no, no, what's It's
complicated cuz we had to go through
everything, but let me let me let's
clean it up.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz we got to be able to explain it to
the sales guys.
>> Yeah.
>> So the offer at the door is going to be
12 months.
And what price are we going to charge at
12 months?
>> For 12 months, we do 30.
>> Up front.
So we're going to do 30.
So that's going to be $360.
>> Yep.
>> If they commit to 6 months,
that's going to be a 35.
>> Okay.
>> So that's 210.
And I'd say we bill biannually.
We bill twice a year.
>> Mhm.
>> And then 3 months.
Do you do ACH?
>> We We just incorporated that actually,
yeah.
>> Okay. Do you have a processing fee?
>> Yeah, so we stripe, so it's
>> Yeah, but like do you don't charge a
processing fee?
>> No, but we
like I've gotten a bunch people to
switch over like offer them a gift card
a small gift card to switch over to ACH,
but then we don't do a
>> Well, I'll tell you really a fancy one.
So, say that you charge the 3%. So, this
is all these are plus processing.
And then if they're like, "Oh, I don't
want to pay the processing fee." It's
all worries. If you want to give a
second form of of payment, we'll waive
the processing fee. It's just because we
have the processing fee just because if
the card declines, it just takes us work
to go redeem it and then you get your
service interrupted and then you have
trash sitting around. So, it's honestly
in everyone's best favor. It's like
honestly, no one ends up paying it. They
just give us two forms.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, thanks.
>> The So, I did actually do that and when
I got the
the prices book that you gave at the
workshop. And
So, I kind of messed it up. I did like
two things. I did like an annual fee and
then I also mentioned, "Oh, yeah, we're
also doing a credit
>> card fee, which is really I was too much
in my head. I was doing too many things.
>> Yeah, but I did that and just I was
looking into how to add the processing
fee and it's like you have to like go to
MasterCard and Visa and all that stuff.
And is that true or like they're they're
saying like you have to legally go to
these
>> companies.
>> Not GPT.
>> Oh, all right. All right. I don't I
think you can just charge 3% more.
>> Oh, we can just do it. Okay.
>> Okay. And just say this is our fee.
>> Okay.
>> You can charge whatever fees you want.
Check with your legal counsel.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
And then three right now, we'll keep it
at
um
We'll keep it at the three-month rate,
which is going to be 35, right? Which is
105.
[__] what is that?
30 105.
>> 105.
>> Right? But we'll still waive the $49
fee.
>> Okay.
>> This one wave is wave's been
and fee.
I think, right? That we had.
Yes. So this gets the discount. So this
gets you the discount
and the bin
and the fee.
So it's like what you like how why is it
so it's like the effective rate
here is
30.
and then here it's also 35
but
bin how are we going to how are we going
to do the bin?
How are we going to work that out?
We're close. This is honestly the most
important thing of today. Like we nail
this you go all in on door-to-door we
can get there by the end of the year and
you're set. So I just want to like make
sure we nail this.
What else do you think it is?
>> So with the bin are you saying that they
pay the full 116 up front?
>> I would love that.
>> Okay.
But like for this one I guess cuz this
is not waived with this with this offer.
>> Well what if so if you didn't have the
bin right what would their actual rate
be? So what do you charge people who
don't who provide their own bin?
>> Yeah the bin is like a few a few
I mean depreciating it over it's use
>> No not the depreciation.
>> Okay. I mean like well what okay fine.
You do you depreciate it over what 3
years is that what is that what it is?
>> They have a 10-year warranty on them so
>> So 10 years is what you depreciate it
over.
So you pay it's like a dollar a month or
something like that.
>> cents yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> How is it a few cents?
>> Yeah cuz over like
>> 116 months
So I'm doing the math wrong? It'd be
doll it'd be dollars not cents.
>> yeah maybe I'm doing that wrong.
>> Well 12 months times 10 is 120. It's a
$116 bin. So it's 90 whatever cents per
per month.
>> Yeah.
Okay so you it's a doll it's a buck.
They don't know that you do that though.
>> No.
>> So that's the thing. So like that's like
that's that's one-sided information.
Don't we'll cut most of this thinking
time out
to figure it out. You know but I want to
I I I think the magic is in this bin. I
actually think that that's I think
that's where the real leverage is.
>> Okay. It is something I've been
wrestling with cuz initially when we
were doing it and we didn't have the
competitor, we were like charging 99 for
like and they were like, "Okay, fine."
But then some people balk at it and I'd
be like, "Okay, fine, we'll wave it."
But most people would pay for it.
Um but now that it's really competitive,
there's like I'm going to go to this
other guy who's giving me 3 months free,
89, and I just have to pay for the
quarter. So.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's become a little bit more
challenging in that sense. Doesn't mean
we can't do it.
>> Yeah.
>> But that had that has been something I
I've done in the past.
Um I think most people were I kind of
played with 99 and then I went down to
50 and most people were like they didn't
really care about 50 as much, but then
like when I did
>> Cuz I like So I like I mean do you
you're currently charging nothing.
>> Yeah.
>> So if we said, "Okay,
upfront we have a $49 bin fee, right?"
>> Yeah.
>> You can buy the bin for 49 bucks.
We know that it doesn't matter, right?
We're just adding what adding what it So
my they'd be like, "Yeah, it feels
reasonable, right?" 49 bucks for the
bin.
And it's $49 initiation.
I don't know, I'm just coming up with
this.
Okay, it's $49 initiation.
And then you have your first quarter,
which is let's just use your old
pricing.
>> Mhm.
>> 89. So that would get us to 190.
We still have commissions.
>> Yeah.
>> But this bin isn't a real cost cuz it's
going to cover towards $42
for the quarter.
That we're we're calling it the bin fee,
but it's really covering our labor
>> Mhm.
>> for the first quarter.
>> Right.
Well, that's clever, yeah.
>> And our initiation is actually our
commission.
>> Mhm.
Mhm. I got you.
>> Yeah.
>> And then our 89 is hopefully
our margin.
This feels okay.
Do you think you can sell this?
>> I think
I think people will be really upset with
the extra 49.
The initiation. Yeah, I think they
understand the bin.
Well, why don't we do this?
>> Yeah.
>> Like we can either basically would you
think they'd be more comfortable with
paying 99 bucks for the bin?
And they own it.
>> Yeah.
>> It's your bin, you keep it forever.
>> Unless you cancel, of course. In which
case we take it back.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, I mean I think that
I'm just like replaying anecdotal
experiences
and here's your turn.
I'm just worried people would be like
Yeah, it's that's a deal breaker for me.
Like I I won't pay that for for the bin
even if I own it. I just don't want to
have to provide it.
Yeah, but what percentage?
You're right. I think it'd only be like
25% or something. I just always remember
the negative, right?
>> Of course. Yeah, I know I get it.
>> Yeah. The thing is this all the new
sales guys coming in aren't going to
know anything.
>> Right.
>> In terms of like what status quo is. So
it's your like here's the deal, guys.
>> Mhm.
>> Like you're going to get paid 50 bucks
on each one of these.
>> Mhm.
>> And you got to you got to collect two
things.
You got to sell them a bin. They got to
pay their first quarter.
>> Mhm.
>> That seems pretty straightforward. And
we can waive the initiation fee.
>> Yeah.
>> And and we still do the three months
free with this or no?
>> Yeah, I think you can still do the free
month the three months free.
>> Okay. I don't hate that.
And dude, just to clarify for myself. So
the bin, it's actually theirs now? So
they're actually paying for it?
>> Well, it's 116, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, so why not? Now, if they if they
cancel before their term then take the
bin back.
>> Right.
>> Which gives you another piece of
collateral.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So all in you lose 16 bucks on the
bin. Who cares?
>> Well, yeah. Yeah, exactly.
>> So I think I think if you go you sell
them the bin.
You have this.
Um
you have the first three months.
Right?
First
quarter.
>> And we're we're in good shape with that.
>> And this factors in and then you have
you give them one free month the next
each of the next quarters.
>> Yeah.
>> And then that means that you're charging
them what 60 on Q2, Q3, Q4?
>> Exactly. 59 and some change.
>> Got it.
>> And so how do we handle situations where
they
where like I'm not going to buy your
bin?
>> It's like you can provide your own.
>> Okay. And so we just wouldn't as a
customer.
>> Yeah, but I mean you can provide your
own if you want.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> You could, if you wanted to, say, "If
you're not willing to do that, we'll
finance it over 3 years, but we end up
charging you 150."
>> Mhm, I like that. Yeah, I really like
that.
>> Cuz then it gives you a 3-year term.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> And then with the 3-year term
budget in like
I don't know, add in like a I don't
know, 4% price increase each year.
>> Sure.
>> Okay.
I think that's it.
>> Feels doable.
>> Yeah.
>> I still want to get this anchor, though,
because we still want to go cuz some
houses are like fine, just if I could
build me one, so I don't want to
>> Mhm. Exactly, yeah.
>> Yeah, and so it's like start at 360.
It's like yes for the year. Okay, so
we're getting close. We're going to do
it we're going to do a cleaner a cleaner
next version of this. All right?
So, all right, I want to think through
it real quick. So,
this is the core offer, right? We'll
clean this up, but it's like 99 bucks
for the bin,
89 for the first quarter. You still get
your 3 months free.
>> Mhm.
>> Cool.
That's fine.
I still want to start higher because
even if we get 20% of people to take,
which we totally will, I'm telling you,
we're going to,
that would be really big for the
business because if we can get this on
the core offer,
and then we can add 80
to the average door,
>> Mhm.
>> then that takes
uh so this is 190 at 80, we're at two
we're at 270.
Right? Average cash collected per sale.
>> Mhm.
>> You're good.
>> Yeah.
>> You're home free.
>> Mhm.
>> Sexy, right?
>> It's way better than right now.
>> That's way better than right now. That
is way better than right now. That's
this that's that's facts. F A F A you
know, it's factual printer. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
So, here's here's where this gets sexy.
Okay, I got it. OKAY.
SO,
ALL RIGHT. OKAY, I THINK THIS IS COMING
TOGETHER. This is coming together. If
someone if someone paid 360 up front,
would you give them the the bin for
free? I think I'd do that, you know.
Okay.
Boom. I think we're just going to have
two offers. Okay, keep it super simple.
We're going to have 12 months.
And with 12 months, they're going to be
at
$30,
right? And they're going to pay 360 in
total,
but
free
$99 bin.
So, they don't have to they don't have
to pay that.
>> Right.
>> Great.
And then the core offer is going to be 3
months
at 30,
but they have to pay for the $99 bin.
And 3 months
up front.
>> Mhm.
>> So, all in they're looking at
180 190 whatever 189.
So, now look at that AB offer.
>> Yeah.
>> So, would you rather pay 360, pay for
the year, I'll give you the bin, it's on
me, or 189, you just pay the first
quarter, but you just got to pay the
bin, right?
>> Right.
Yeah, I like that.
Now, we just got to hustle.
>> Yeah, but the nice thing is that this
keeps it super simple. The billable is
the same. All we're debating is who gets
the free bin and who doesn't. You get
the free bin when you commit for the
year. Cuz listen, it costs me money to
do this, but if you commit for that
period of time, I'll throw it in, right?
Like it actually costs us 116. So, like
I'll be like we we actually lose a
little bit of money on these bins. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> But if you commit to us, we'll commit to
you.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> And then our breakdown is, let's say,
now let's look at the math.
So let's say 80%
take our
$189
dollar offer, and then 20% take our
$360 offer
equals
$72.
And this equals
service says
Michael, Jamie.
Jamie.
Well, it's 19.2
is 270
is $27 off this,
which is
162.
So we add this together.
Average per door.
And we needed 208.
Yeah.
And then you're home free.
Doable?
>> Yeah, I just I've never thought about
that way.
>> You still get three You still get three
Like the offers are banging.
>> Yeah.
>> It's like you get three Like the offer's
great because you're getting three
months free either way. Yeah. So I would
And that way I think it you've got this
great feel, right?
You say, "Listen, we're going to give
you three months free either way just
because you're switching to us. So we're
happy to do that. But if you're willing
to commit to a a whole year
give you the bid."
>> Right.
>> If you don't want that, no worries.
We'll get you set up. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> What are you going to do?
What are you going to do with all this
money?
>> Yeah, I don't know.
>> All right. So that's that's the that's
the play. That's the play. And for for
our folks at home,
the reason that that was so important is
that we needed to get above $208
because he had a $50 commission that he
has to pay.
And we knew we had $42 of labor.
And we know that he had these bins that
he's been basically fronting the cost
for for customers. Now, to be clear, as
of right now, what was the other cost
though? There was something else.
There's labor, there's commission, and
there's something else.
>> No, I think it was just the bins.
>> Oh, so I'm just being greedy. That
works. Okay. So then we got Yeah, yeah.
Well, I like to have I like to grow
businesses debt free
if I can.
>> Me, too.
>> Cuz I just think there's there's always
a way if you just think about hard
enough. And so the bins, which right now
he's been financing over 10 years for
$116. But when we add all these things
together, we get to 208. And so in a
perfectly debt-free, cash flow positive
way of growing the business, we have to
get like on average over $208 to to
break even up front and have really high
really strong cash flow for the
business, which has been the biggest
constraint for you.
So,
getting above that is the objective. And
so what we did was we solved for it by
having an anchor on the top that we know
20% of people are going to take. And
that contributes an extra $72 a door
where the core offer is going to be 190,
which already solves this.
>> Mhm.
>> Cool. That was for everyone back home.
Okay.
Now let's go back to our our handy dandy
Isn't this fun? It's a lot of fun.
Okay.
So, we have our our new offer, our 360
for 12 or 12 at
at 360, and then we have our 3189.
Money. And if you really get wild with
that and you're like, you know what? I
don't need all the extra cash that you
can pay the guys 100 bucks a day. 100
bucks a deal.
>> Mhm.
>> And they'll be willing to sell more. If
you're like, you know what? I don't need
all the cat like I'd rather just get
more aggressive on the spend.
>> Yeah.
>> You can get way better guys. If the guys
can make I'll tell you the difference in
sales when you can get at $500 a day,
$15,000 a month, almost $200,000 a year,
like a different an order of magnitude
better sales person.
>> The thing is is those guys might be
doing like and that order of magnitude
better sales person might do 10 deals a
day.
>> Yeah.
>> Because the guys who really do
door-to-door, they run between doors.
>> Really? Okay.
>> 100%.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz they know it's a numbers game.
>> Yeah.
>> They're like, "For every 12 doors I
knock on, I'm going to get a sale. So,
if I run" I mean, that's why the UPS
guys like the guys who who are who are
commissioned and are really understand
the game, they sprint back and forth.
>> Mhm.
>> Because you can cover four times the
doors just by walking fast. They cut
across the lawn. They don't go on the on
the sidewalk. Like they're moving.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> Oh.
>> So, we're going to scatter.
We're going door-to-door as our channel.
We have our offer, our 12 our our AB
offer, which is great. The extra guys
get the bin. Awesome. And now we don't
even have to have a financing partner.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you want, you can and just
collect the cash.
>> Right.
>> The the next thing is let's talk about
sales process
on how we're going to teach these guys.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. How do you teach your guys right
now and what's the sales process?
>> Pretty relaxed. I mean, he's the first
guy I've done so I just I just take him
door-to-door, show him how I do it.
>> Mhm.
>> And I generally tell him what's
>> sits right next to you?
>> Pardon me?
>> He sits right next to you?
>> Yes, exactly.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And then I'll do that for a few
times, show him how it works, show him
how to get a few sales and then I watch
him do it and let him just kind of go at
it and then chime in if I need to. And
then
eventually just kind of like give him
critiques whenever I see
>> How many doors can you knock a day?
>> I think
I think easy like uh 150.
>> Okay.
>> If you're out there for 8 hours, yeah.
>> So, 150 doors. If he's closing what I
mean, if he if he gets to what you're
doing, one out of 12,
>> Yeah.
>> right? Then he's closing more than 10
deals a day.
>> Mhm.
>> Which is chill. Even at 50.
>> That's what I hear on average like
conservatively you can get 10, but most
guys get 15.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the nice thing with your business is
that you're going to be in person with
them and so you you there's basically
two primary ways that people learn. One
is modeling and the other is basically
doing it. So, children learn through
modeling. They watch you do something
and then they learn it, right?
Alternatively, you take it up a notch
when you give feedback. And so, doing
role plays like in very real time with
them is going to be the fastest way to
speed up the lip. Okay. So, it's
literally just like have the door at
your facility or whatever. Like I mean,
you want to you really want to get them
in the like in the mechanics of I say
this is the door opens. Like it'll it it
will teach that. Like don't just stand
next to them. Like close the door, open
the door, close the door, open the door,
close the door, open the door until they
just nail it every time cuz you know the
first 5 seconds of them opening the door
is like that's the only shot you really
have and they're making their split
second decision. And so, it's like you
have to drill the opener super hard so
they could just say it in their sleep
and they say it the right way every
time. But, they should absolutely be
following a script. And for this type of
sale, this script should I mean, how
long does it take you to do a sale for
these?
>> 2 minutes.
>> Yeah. Right. So, they're not super hard
sales. And so, the sales script is going
to be like four questions. It's not a
lot. Right? And so, it's just like cool,
here's our door here's our knock here's
our open. And then question one,
question two, close question, overcomes.
Like that's it. And so, I would just
drill honestly the drilling the three or
four questions is not going to be tough.
Then you're just going to do traditional
sales training where you're just going
to be like I have to think about it. I'm
not sure. I have to check with my
spouse. Like all that. I don't have the
the card that I want on me.
>> Yeah.
>> And when you're when you're collecting
do you have a lot of people do you have
any people who are like oh, I don't have
the card that I want to use on me?
>> So, we actually don't collect money at
the door.
>> Why?
>> We just have a contract that we sign.
>> Okay.
>> I heard that it was uh
I don't know. I I just heard that it was
a you have to have certain permits to
collect money at the door. So, then I
don't have that permit yet.
>> But, they put a credit card number down,
right?
>> No.
>> What?
>> And we're still get but people are still
signing up.
>> What percentage of people who sign
contracts don't end up giving you the
card.
>> Uh none of them really.
And if we haven't I mean we haven't done
the volume we're we're talking about
right now. So, I'm sure there would be a
ton of people.
>> Okay.
So, you then call them back later?
>> I send them an invoice and then if they
don't complete it, I'll follow up and
>> And everyone pays.
>> Yeah.
What are we doing, Michael?
We should be selling we should be
selling trash. What are we doing?
>> Well, they need it. Yeah, I mean
>> Well, if it's not a constraint, then I'm
not going to mess with it. But I do
think you probably tighten the sales
process in terms of the training.
That's absurd what you just said. I I
don't know in terms of compliance for
that, so check with an attorney, but I'm
I'm pretty sure you can just ask someone
to buy something.
>> Okay.
>> I'm like pretty
feel pretty confident in that.
>> not.
>> But but but
>> You know, it hasn't been an issue, and
so if you really do collect 100%, it's
certainly a less friction a lower
friction sale.
But a contract without a payment clause
I don't think it's nothing.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> that you're getting it is great. The
fact that you're getting it is great.
Okay, let's pull up the ads in the
funnel real quick.
Okay. So,
yeah, just go just go funnel. So, ads,
sorry.
Okay. So, I think I think this is fine.
I read the copy. I think it it it checks
the boxes in terms of a normal offer.
Uh the video ad that I saw that was your
best performer was unsurprising to me
that it was the best performer.
Bottom link.
There you go.
>> If you're a homeowner in Centreville,
Chantilly, Clifton, or Fairfax and you
want to save hundreds on your trash
collection this year, this is for you.
My name is Philip and I'm the owner of
Garbage Disposal Services. We're a local
family-owned and operated business in
Centreville area and we're here to help
take care of your trash. So, if you're
tired of things like increasing bills
every year, crazy prices, unreliable
pickups, then we might be the ones for
you to help give you some more
consistency, ease of mind, and
stress-free trash collection. If that
sounds good to you, click the link down
below so we can give you a quote for
trash collection in your area so you can
start saving money and stop worrying
about your trash collection.
>> It's so cringe.
>> No, it's cuz your highest performing ad.
The thing is it seemed authentic.
>> Yeah, oh yeah, right.
>> And it also hit the the core pieces like
this is for so-and-so. I do think you
introduce yourself first rather than
talking about them, but
>> Okay.
>> like you can you can I would probably
make it offer-driven first. Pain Pain
Pain of like, "Hey, what you said at the
end like, 'Hey, if you're tired of X, Y,
and Z, blah blah blah, I'm so-and-so."
>> Okay.
>> Because it's like leading more with the
things that they're interested in. And
so I basically I would just flip the
script on that and then I would record
10 different versions of that with you
in different shirts and different
backgrounds with the truck with a bin
behind you with a neighbor behind you.
Like I would just do as many variations
of that
>> Yeah.
>> if I was going to do uh paid ads, but
we're not going to do that because we're
doing door-to-door.
>> So you want to just cut it off
completely?
>> don't think you need it. I think all of
your attention should go to I need to
get 10 guys that are commission only
that are going to sell this offer.
>> And just only focus on that.
>> Yeah.
>> That's it. I mean like if we only have
one thing to be true in order for this
business to be profitable, then let's
just pick that and then just put all of
our effort on that one thing. I mean
fundamentally it's the idea of leverage.
>> Yeah.
>> It's like find the one thing that gives
you the greatest output. It also has no
risk on cash flow for you
>> Mhm.
>> cuz they're commission only.
>> Yeah.
>> The perfect solution doesn't ex-
>> Except when it does.
>> That's it.
>> AB offer, 12-month, 3-month, 20% take
the 12, 80% take the main. We're cash
flow positive on both. You don't even
need to go into debt for the the bins.
>> Mhm.
>> You get 10 guys closing five deals a
day, it's 50 deals a day.
>> Yeah.
>> That's it.
>> And then And it's way way easier to
close than solar.
You can probably get some of those guys.
They're just tired of like, "Dude,
you're like it's it's such a such a
better life to to just know you're going
to close deals every day
>> Yeah.
>> rather than be like knocking doors for 5
days and closing one or two.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's a much more
you know, energizing way to live.
>> Yeah, no, for sure.
I think my next constraint would be then
getting the sales guys.
>> Yeah, let's talk about that. Yeah. So
right now, so I would say
if like
you can handle more volume, right? You
don't have to really change anything
about your infrastructure to handle the
volume that you would be getting from
these sales guys?
>> I think after a certain point we would
need to get another truck.
>> Well, let's we can temporarily deal with
that. Yeah, yeah. So to get to your
3,000 whatever it was number
>> Mhm.
>> how much can you take if you were full
capacity, how many customers can you can
you handle?
>> I think we could do 3,500.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean dude, like 3,500 we got 1,000
more customers to sell.
>> Yeah.
>> So you got to sell
I mean in 6 months, let's call it 5
months, that's 200 customers at seven
customers a day. I mean you're
if you get a second guy, you'll be doing
that.
>> Right.
>> in 6 months.
>> Could be me.
>> Yeah. Could be you.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So
is that going to be an issue?
Because I mean do you have the cash to
get by to the truck?
>> I think I can figure out a way to get
one.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So the way to do it is I I think that
you could given the nature of this job,
I would be looking at running like
Indeed ads
or Craigslist.
>> Yeah.
>> That would just probably be the easiest
thing for you to and then you just need
to work these like it's a lead funnel,
right? And so like if you're not getting
people, so it'd be like
like you have to think about this like
as a true ad. So a lot of people try to
like ward people off. It's like dude,
it's an ad. It's the same thing. It's
like you're going to run an ad, you have
to have a headline, it has to be
appealing, the cop the body copy has to
be interesting, which is like, "Hey, you
can work 4 hours or 8 hours a day. The
guys who work 8 hours make this, the
guys who work 4 hours do this." Instead
of the other alternatives you have of
like you have to be able to ask four
questions to somebody at the door. Like
break it down to what they're going to
have to do.
>> Yeah.
>> It's like if you can memorize four
questions
then you could be able to make a
six-figure or multi-six-figure per year
income as long as you're are to be in in
the street. But then I do damaging
admission. It's like, "Hey, sometimes
it's going to be hot, sometimes it's
going to be cold. That's the trade. But
if you're somebody who's like just
barely graduated high school, we don't
care about your grades. We care about
your work ethic."
>> Yeah.
>> Like I think that would attract plenty
of people.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's just add Indeed and those
ones already have kind of like applicant
funnels that are built into it. And so
basically if we're turning off all these
extra things that you're spending all
this time like fragmented time on, this
is all you do.
>> Yeah.
>> You go get sales people.
>> And honestly all you need like you need
like two guys just to get this going.
>> Yeah.
>> That's it.
>> That makes a lot of sense. Yeah.
>> Baby offer, two guys, four questions.
That's it. Let's go.
>> Yeah. I've been doing Indeed ads and but
I haven't been structuring it like that.
>> No, it's like
>> Yeah, exactly.
It's been more just like the traditional
like corporate
>> Yeah, but the thing is you have to think
about who's responding to this.
>> Yeah.
>> Write it to that to the salesman.
>> Right.
>> Cuz that's who you're trying to attract.
>> Like what are all the things that you
either hate about your current job or
you hate about your current sales job?
Both those are the pains. What are the
what's the promise? You can make six
figures, you know, a year or more and
you can work four or eight hours a day.
I'll take you on either. So some guys
will work, you know, 7:00 to noon or
7:00 to 11:00 and then they go to their
other job by noon and they work, you
know, 12:00 to 8:00 cuz they're
providing for family.
>> Yeah.
>> So this is a great opportunity for you.
>> And then I'll work on that immediately.
Yeah.
>> So I'll give you the the truth about
this. So
for a job where someone's coming in
commission only, my bar is relatively
low because I'd rather give more people
the opportunity to take a shot and like
prove that they have work ethic rather
than they have the skill of
interviewing, which is a different
skill. I basically would just screen for
crazies.
>> Okay.
>> I would just screen for crazies and
because if you're going to do this,
you're probably going to get a lot of
applications. Definitely don't do
one-on-one interviews. You're going to
be doing group calls. So bunch of people
on, two minutes tell me who you are, two
minutes two two minutes two minutes,
whatever. And then invite the ones who
seem normal to your, you know, your
warehouse or whatever. Meet them in
person, give job offers on the spot,
tell them they can start. Okay.
I just don't think you have to
overcomplicate this. And so, it's like,
cool, what we're going to do is we're
going to do shadow for a week, and then
we're going to break you off in twos,
and then that's it. Like, you're good to
go. And the thing is here is like, if
you wanted to, like, this is this is me
talking about how to you aggressively
scale sales. Like, you need like two
guys.
>> Yeah.
>> So, like,
>> get on a group call, talk to a bunch of
them. The guy who seems cool and normal
and hardworking, invite two or three of
those guys out because a bunch of them
are going to are going to last, right?
Because it is door-to-door and there are
there are some risk there.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, like, maybe you hire five to get
one. Okay. Just lower the bar. Like,
you're not looking for somebody to cure
cancer here. You need someone to ask
four questions and be able to fill out a
form.
>> Yeah, definitely. Cuz, I mean, like I
said, me, I'm not like the best salesman
in the world, but I can go up there and
sell.
>> Sure. But, you think it's cuz you seem
trustworthy.
>> You think so?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So, and you're also the business owner,
so it's like
>> Yeah, I think that's a big
>> you have a star power. So, but with them
though, I think what the one thing that
I'm looking for is hunger.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, I think that'll typically skew
to either young single guys who are just
like really hungry and like go-getters,
or people who just are about to have
like a kid on the way, like you are.
You're more hungry now than you probably
were.
Right? Cuz you're like cuz you have to
be.
>> Yes.
>> It's like, you know why married married
men with kids make more money than guys
who are single without being married and
don't have kids?
Because they have to.
>> Yeah.
>> That's why they make more money.
>> I mean, yeah.
>> So, they they literally choose to make
more money because they have no choice.
>> Yeah, that's that's definitely how I
feel.
>> Yeah, right. And so, you're doing it.
And so, basically, like, I just look for
someone's circumstances of like, why do
they need this?
>> Yeah.
>> If someone's like hungry, then I'm
especially in a job like this. This is
so work ethic driven. They're not going
to run out of houses.
>> Yeah.
>> For sure. Right.
>> So, would you say I should just not do
any more door-to-door and just train the
guys?
>> Well, I think you can I mean, you're
going to be doing door-to-door
>> Okay, yeah.
>> in the training.
>> So, your sales isn't going to go down.
You're just going to have more people so
you can duplicate it.
>> Right. Okay.
Makes sense.
>> Two birds on stone.
>> Yep.
>> Basically, as far as I'm concerned, I
want you to keep doing door-to-door
because if you've got your guy and
you've got you, you guys start doing 10
10 deals a day, just you two, you're at
300 a month. You need In 3 months,
you're at your thousand.
Forget everything else.
In 3 months, you're at a thousand.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? But, as far as you're concerned,
I don't think you should ever do
something alone.
>> Okay.
>> So, you have the skill set.
You should have somebody always watching
you so that you're basically you're
getting you're getting two birds on
stone, right? You're getting You're
double dipping on effort.
>> Yeah.
>> So, someone's always with you because
you're the lead sales person, and
they're learning until eventually
somebody else is the best sales person,
you pass out, you you know, you step out
Homer Simpson style into the bushes, and
then they they slide up, and then they
become lead trainer. And if you want,
you say, "Hey, I'll give you 60 bucks a
sale instead of 50 because it's a little
harder to have somebody else with you."
>> Right.
Makes a lot of sense.
>> Easy.
>> Yeah.
Cool.
>> I feel like this is it. So, let's let's
do a quick recap here.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's do a quick recap, and we'll
prioritize it, but it's going to be an
easy list.
Simple, not easy. How about that?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
So,
make it blue for you, Michael. All
right. I know Michael really wanted the
blue. He was like, "All right."
So, the first thing we're going to do is
we made the decision to go scatter as
our avatar. All right? So, that's
decision number one, which we just did
instantly, but there we go.
Number two is we switched our offer. So,
we have now an AB
offer
first offer for 3 months free.
And so, offer A is going to be 189,
and then 60 per month after that.
And then offer B
is 360
free
bid.
That's our deal. Yep.
Three.
Indeed ads.
I'd also hit up your network. You only
need a couple, right? Indeed ads into
group
call.
Or you can just honestly invite them all
in person if you want, but sometimes
people are really crazy, so the
2-minute, you know, call. In person.
And then tag along.
And role playing until your eyes bleed.
And the nice thing is that basically
document, demonstrate, duplicate is the
process that we use. And so like the
document is like you have the script,
they memorize it while you're walking
between doors, you're just like you're
you're role playing it back and forth.
What do you say? What do you say? What
do you say? Yeah. Demonstrate, you do it
in front of them. Hey, watch me follow
the script. Watch me close deals. Now,
duplicate, you knock, I'll be here. I'll
ride shotgun and I'll watch you do it so
you can give immediate feedback. Okay.
That's it. And then in terms of
I mean, [__] What like what's the
what's the outcome of this? The outcome
of all of this is that you are cash
flow
positive.
And
babies
have
food.
Smiley face. Yeah.
Yeah.
Feel better?
>> I do.
>> This is all clear?
>> It does. Yeah.
>> That's it.
>> Yeah, give me instructions and I'll go
out.
>> That's it. That's all you have to do.
And the nice thing is one and two is
instant.
>> Yeah.
>> You literally just have to do this.
>> Right.
>> Go hire five more sales guys.
>> I think this is the this is the play.
>> Yeah.
I think so, too.
>> Doesn't this feel like like the noise in
the world like
quiet?
>> I was doing way too much. Of course you
were doing way too much.
>> think I was like
>> You two different avatars and five
different acquisition processes.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> When there's just one that if we just
did this well,
>> Yeah.
>> we can solve the cash flow issue,
and we can hit your hit your extra
thousand in the next like 90 days.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a quarter. It's nothing.
>> Mhm.
>> Feel good?
>> I appreciate it.
>> You're welcome. I told you we we'd get
through it.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a fill-up. I'm rooting for you. If
you enjoyed this and you want to see a
different business that went from
negative to positive in one
conversation, check out this
conversation with Lex Lamar. He's a
legal person who does legal things for
musicians so that they can get contracts
and incorporated and whatever musicians
do to make money.